thank you very
much okay thank you love you too thank
you I know why you're happy Halloween is
over
I I know it's fun but it's just it's
exhausted
kids kids you know I do the same
thing every year I dress up as a priest
and then they just run
away but oh I kid the
Catholic but yes it's also the time will
we set our clocks back this week yeah
and after electing Mike Johnson as
Speaker this is twice in one week for
the
Republican you seen this guy super
uh I mean there's Christy and then
there's Christy this
m this this Mike Johnson and listen to
this this is just weird out of left
field we found out about him this week
because we don't know this guy uh has no
bank account
I'm not making it they cannot find any
tra no bank account no savings account
no Stu what is he a
pimp
no who in this what's
he that's what we need a speaker of the
house who's Off the Grid that's gives me
a lot of confidence so the first thing
he wants to do is uh you know we voted
all this money to beef up the IRS which
we need because a lot of tax cheats he
wants to take some of that money away
$14 billion take that away which they
did the score and they found it actually
adds the to the
debt so you seem M this is what happens
when you use only Christian
accountants um oh yeah speaking of that
the FBI director Christopher Ray he
testified at the Senate panel on
anti-Semitism it is at historic levels
the Threat Level they say is gone from
Mel Gibson to
Kanye no it's uh it's it's not funny and
especially in a city like this we have a
lot of Jewish people couple here today I
hope okay all right but we see it I mean
caner Deli it's right down the street
here you saw this vandalized people
wrote on it things like Israel's only
religion is capitalism and how many dead
in the name of greed they wrote Of
course that one was just about the
pastrami
but oh we make little
jokes but yes the ground war has now
started in the Middle East in Gaza the
Israeli troops are going building by
building hoping to root out Hamas
supporting radicals and if it works
there they're going to try it at
Cornell